now a Myanmar government delegation has
visited rohingya refugee camps in
Bangladesh as part of a repatriation
scheme it's the second such visit in the
past three months Bangladesh and Myanmar
want to send more than 1 000 rohingya to
Myanmar
some of the refugees say they've been
forced or coerced into signing
repatriation documents about a million
of them fled Myanmar in 2017 after a
military Crackdown
let's speak now with the tanveer charger
he's in a Badu Kali camp in Cox's Bazaar
so time here first up this effort to
repatriate 1 000 rohingya refugees what
more about us
well there's a serious effort on part of
the government to make these pilot
projects a success now talking to many
of the rohingyas even some who are in
the list among this thousand plus
refugees who the Myanmar delegation
verified are eligible to be repatriated
now some of them told us that they do
want to go but not under current
circumstances feel though did volunteer
to go but some of them said that we have
been caused by the government although
we do want to go but not under the
current circumstances now there was a
team of rohingya along with the
Bangladesh government delegation who
visited Myanmar recently to see how
conducive the environment is now the
government feels pretty confident that
it's allowable for the rohingyas to
repatio right now but some of the
rohingyas again say that it's still not
conducive what is more important they
need some sort of security Assurance
from the U.N that that's up with some of
The Observer there or some sort of
presence to make sure that they're
treated well they don't want to be in a
situation like many of the rohingyas are
in intern camp now the rohingya is also
are concerned about them not recognized
as rohinga's ethnic group they have not
been given the citizenship only thing
they'll get is something called NVC and
National verification card essentially
it's an identity card that says you are
a Bengali Muslim that's all it doesn't
say whether from Myanmar for Bangladesh
only other document they carry here is a
Biometrics card issued by the unhcr and
Bangladesh government many of them lost
their old documents to prove that
they're from Myanmar land documents and
other stuff so all this put is a very
complex Affair it is a honest sincere
effort by the government brokered by the
Chinese they've been making this effort
this is the second visit so there is a
very strong sincere effort to start the
process maybe a thousand now down the
road more but this is a project that
that want to have a success and they
want to convince the rohingyas look we
want to make sure that you're secured
and safe we'll assure that the rohingya
some are skeptic and I'm totally
convinced okay conditions of course very
tough Nick for the refugees and we're
hearing news that Russians are being cut
yes it's absolutely a very horrid
condition you can see behind me we are
in Camp 11 Balu Cali is 32 of the camps
that within 17 square kilometer area 1.2
million approximately refugees live in
this cramped area with just attached
roof made out of tarpaulin some cases
chain roof and the rest is bamboo panels
and bamboo you know pole that holding
those just about a week ago we had a
cyclone mura here luckily it was spared
still about thousand Huts were blown off
now considering everything the on March
the wfp announced that cutting the
Russian back from 12 to 10 and again
this week they announced that from June
1 which is tomorrow they're going to cut
it down to eight dollars that's coming
down to basically U.S nine cents per
meal per person so it's grossly
inadequate and they need at least 56
million dollar to go back to the status
quo The Joint response students is
asking for money otherwise there's it's
gonna be a serious shortcoming in the
food supply for the Russian among the
rohingyas who are very concerned because
at least 12 percent children are still
suffering from malnourishment 45 percent
of the people don't get adequate food in
this camp
that's a picture of the battle Khali
camp at Cox's bizarre tan bear thanks
very much time for charger there